pastor leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video
ich habe heute wie kann ich das denn wie
kann ich dich jetzt am besten auf jeden
fall kann ich ihnen schon ganz lange wir
fahren seit sehr langer zeit ab und zu
mal zusammen in urlaub er ist einfach
viel jünger als ich aber eigentlich
genauso groß wie ich auf jeden fall
macht er auf you tube und haben uns
gedacht wir machen einfach mal ein video
zusammen ich glaube du blogs den tag
heute
naja ich hab mir so nicht so viel aber
ein bisschen also trifft auf jeden fall
mal seinen blog am ende des videos und
wir machen heute den heftigsten ihr habt
wahrscheinlich gerade vor dem ende schon
gesehen den heftigsten buttle flip den
die welt je gesehen hat und wir sind mal
gespannt ob der klappt aber ich bin
relativ zuversichtlich aber erst mal
müsst ihr uns natürlich ein bisschen
wahr machen
ich würde sagen ein paar krasse potter
films machen auch schon mal vorweg und
dann zum schluss kommt wirklich was
krasses ach so er heißt übrigens timon
ja ich bin thema ja ich würde sagen erst
mal das video gucken dann könnt ihr
seine stelle abonnieren
und wir fangen jetzt an
[Musik]
okay das ist jetzt viel internet crime
und andere waffen clips ablauf jetzt
machen wir das ganz auf dem klodeckel
zum beispiel einfach so
das war fällt so meine ich meine
natürlich so dass kann ich sah es im klo
einfach so
jetzt liegen ich hab ihn ist es ganz
oben drauf werfen ganz okay leute die
nächsten beiden klubs machen jetzt da
wir merken jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen die leute hier in ok danke das
ausland geschehen so leute herzlich
willkommen zum kratzen bottle flip zum
heftigsten bottle oder buttle zum
krassesten bottle flip der welt den die
welt je gesehen hat kommt mal kurz mit
ich zeige euch mal kurz was sie draußen
in meiner haut so abgeht
ok dafür angst dass gegen die auf dem
paket werfen
durch machen hey leute hier unter das
sind locker das locker 40 meter ohne
spaß
es muss klar okay 141 sein versuch okay
leute passt aufpasst
ich glaube es hat geklappt begeistert
geklappt
das muss schon runter gehen okay leute
runden und wir gucken mal auf die
flasche steht ich hoffe so dass wir
einfach so gar nicht denn ich bin
richtig
wir haben viel stress
unsere flasche und auf dem boden muss
stehen nicht schlecht gefahren gewisser
weise zum video
war diese von den ganzen abend diese
flasche hier runter ich erzähle ich
denke hier hin da hinstellen und da seid
ihr auch den ganzen tag stehen
das gibt's nicht
ich kann
timo von der ganzen
das wars mit diesem video gehofft
natürlich es hat euch gefallen jetzt
schlägt auf jeden fall mal hier ein
gewinnerteam ans kanaren lassen aber da
ich würd mal sagen wie viele abonnenten
hast du keine ahnung auf jeden fall geht
an auf seinen zettel und abonniert hin
dann bleibt das ganze auch geblockt
heute schaut euch das auf jeden fall mal
würde mich freuen wenn es noch was sagen
sag einfach kommt abonniert mich ich
will 5000 abos haben dann schaffst du
vielleicht auch drei für 5000 ich kann
sich sagen aber eigentlich sehr locker
süß oder kann man aber verweigert
wir sehen uns morgen hast du das gerade
gesagt hast du es mir heute wirklich
gesagt
[Musik]
langweilig ist für mein video und fängt
an mich zu filmen das nehme ich mit rein
ja